chaque fois que West le fait me remplir, c'est
tout un monde et ce n'est pas
le scénario, il
faut créer tout un univers avec le grand
hôtel de Budapest qui se déroule en Europe une
partie fictive de l'Europe centrale
appelée la République de Dubrovka c'était
'  t cette époque incroyable appelée fille,
c'est dans ce qui était autrefois l'Allemagne de l'Est,
juste à côté de la Pologne, ce qui était
très magique dans la neige, je veux dire
vraiment magique dans la neige, la ville
a tellement de caractère dans tous ces
différents bâtiments, salles et choses
qui  cette ville est en effet devenue
nebelsbad qui est une ville de Sbrocco
beaucoup le film se déroule c'est un
pays fictif il ouvre toutes
ces opportunités de faire des choses vraiment très
amusantes nous avons construit toute une gamme de
documents et de signalisation Dubrovnik et des
passeports avec des voisins à l'étranger  peut
signaler la devise que nous avons conçue klubecks pour
Zubrowka avec un peu de chance elle a laissé quelques
klubecks pour votre vieil ami mais on
ne sait jamais jusqu'à l'encre Australie la
mort  certificat nous avons inventé des lignes de bus
et des lignes de train et des journaux et des
choses que nous ne faisons qu'entrevoir
mais chacun d'entre eux est impeccable
quand nous terminons le scénario, il s'est mis
à déterminer où ce film
pourrait être fait et à un moment donné nous sommes venus
à travers cette ville allemande appelée gorlitz alors
que nous regardions de plus en plus autour de cette
ville, bien sûr, nous avons continué à trouver d'autres
endroits que nous pensions parfaits
pour d'autres scènes du film et la
ville est tellement intacte et il y a
tellement de caractère dans tous ces différents
bâtiments et  halls, nous avons commencé à réaliser
que nous pouvions à peu près faire
tout le film dans cette ville Garlits est à
cette intersection de l'Allemagne, de la Pologne et de la
République tchèque et nos histoires sur
ce qui s'est passé dans ces endroits, bonjour les
gars, c'était bien pour le film,
les lieux se sentaient bien  Je veux dire que nous étions
très c'était le milieu de l'hiver les
jours étaient courts la neige était épaisse il
faisait froid en dehors du type d'endroit
aussi c'est si petit  l que pendant le
week-end vous savez que tout le monde est ensemble de
toute façon tout le monde traîne toujours et
donc il y a une vraie camaraderie c'est
là que nous vivons c'est la force de l'hôtel
c'est une expérience vivante nous vivons
cette vie dans cet hôtel dans cette
belle petite ville préservée